hi there Steve Kaufman questions and
answers we did it I did it with my son's
last time and we did another one with
mark but somehow I bungled getting that
video into my computer or uploaded to
YouTube and so unfortunately you're just
gonna have to have me reading the
questions which come from my youtube
channel questions that you the viewers
and listeners have have asked me so the
first one was I'm interested in the
process of reviewing vocabulary by
reading on link how do you do it and how
often do you stand one one lesson before
going to the next one how long I stay
depends on where I am in the language if
as a beginner I'll tend to read very
often because when you read you kind of
sort of understand by looking up the
words then you listen and you don't
understand and you read again and so it
could be four or five six ten times not
necessarily staying with one but maybe
doing one two three four five back to
one two three four five lessons like I
think but as soon as I get to where I
can start to understand more I tend to
move on even if I don't fully understand
because in fact I am reviewing all of
the vocabulary it just shows up in
different contexts but it's very often
the same words I see them because once
I've saved them they're in yellow at
link I I read quite quickly now because
I use the auto mode so with it with the
keypad I can just move to the next blue
word than the next yellow word learn a
new word look up a word or look at a
word that I just saved so it actually
goes quite quickly and I'm motivated
then by my interest in the subject which
right now is say polish history so
that's how I do that second question any
languages you don't use as much as you
had hoped of course
I'm now on my sixteenth language I can't
possibly find the time to to read books
and and listen to interesting things in
all of those sixteen languages so I have
to focus on the one that I'm working on
right now which
polish with a little bit in some of the
other languages I don't have the time to
even for Polish to go and find the local
Polish community and spend my whole time
hobnobbing with people with whom I can
practice the language not that motivated
to stumble with people online I am gonna
start speaking some polish but yeah you
can't you know to me I advantage of
learning about another country and
another language is is an advantage
which outweighs the disadvantage of not
being able to spend enough time with
those languages that I also already have
learned to some degree next question
our cultural barriers stronger than the
difference in just the language no not
at all you know having exposed myself to
fifteen or sixteen different cultures
I'm always impressed by how
fundamentally similar all human beings
are you learn about the culture through
the language but it's not a barrier as
long as you're interested I never worry
as some people you know when in Japan
people work well if I don't get the
politeness level right I might offend
someone I find that you can't offend
people and anyone who is offended
because you as a foreigner don't use
their language correctly isn't worth
worrying about
I don't worry about cultural barriers at
all but of course you want to be
sensitive to to you know how different
cultures operate but I don't worry about
making a cultural booboo hardest
language I mean it depends obviously the
more similar a new languages to a
language you already know the easier
it's going to be Chinese had nothing in
common with English it was difficult for
me Russian was difficult Czech was
easier Ukrainian was even easier and
polish is even easier you know Spanish
Portuguese a time so it's all a matter
of how related the languages to a
language you already know reading and
listening and speaking is covered but
what how do you write how do you
approach it how does it
differ as you go through different
levels in the language okay
writing is tremendously powerful as a
way to learn I don't have the discipline
to do it now I did a lot of writing
obviously when I learned French because
I was a student in France for three
years we had to write all of our exams
in French when I studied Chinese eight
months full time nine months full time I
had to write and writing is tremendously
powerful the main advantage of writing
is the fact that you write that you're
forcing your brain to think about words
you might be looking things up and so
you put a degree of preparation and a
degree of thoroughness into into your
writing that you can't do while speaking
and it helps prepare you for speaking so
it's obviously a great thing to do if
you have the motivation and the patience
to do it I learned for fun now so I
don't bother writing but it and and the
advantage is not that someone's gonna
correct it the advantages that you write
the more you write the better the
corrections find if people correct you
if they don't correct you that's fine
too
you'll eventually start to notice most
of your mistakes okay what is your view
on learning similar languages is there
any point of course there's a point I
mean I can remember going to Portugal
for the first time and people would
speak to me in English because yeah I
might understand and speak Spanish I
couldn't really understand them very
well and actually it was a fair amount
of work to get used to Portuguese so
similar languages gives you an advantage
but there is definitely a point you know
and I think sometimes there's a bit of
difficulty say going from Spanish to
Portuguese and you're reluctant to move
from Spanish pronunciation to Portuguese
pronunciation so you kind of have
pronounced the knew that language and
the new word the way it would be
pronounced in the language that you know
better let's say Spanish but every
language is different every language is
well worth it
blah blah blah okay breathing's lots of
pleasant which I appreciate
birthday greetings here that similar
question here do you have any thoughts
about learning the dialect of a language
your core does it help or hinder well
what's a dialect I mean is Portuguese a
dialect of Spanish is Cantonese a
dialect of manner and you could argue
that Cantonese has many more speakers
certainly that in Portugal now of course
in Brazil they have many more speakers I
think it enriches your hold on the
language you're covering you're covering
some of the same vocabulary even now and
I you know from Russian than I do
Czech and Ukrainian I'm reinforcing my
grasp on sort of the fundamental in ways
Slavic languages operate so so yeah it's
well worth it and it doesn't hurt you ii
you stress the important knowing lots of
words why do you think some polyglot so
steadfastly insist that you only need to
know X words till you just find in a
language well I'm just going from
experience I find like I enjoy reading
and I enjoy listening to podcasts if I
don't understand them it's not because
of the grammar it's because I don't know
the key words I also find that when I
speak to native speakers
it doesn't help but if I can say a few
simple things in the language if I don't
understand what they're saying if I'm
out with people and they're chatting and
I don't understand what they're talking
about if I watch a movie and I don't
understand the movie so and what's
lacking typically is the words so I
don't understand why some people say you
only need a few words it has not been my
experience my experience has been that
you need a lot of words no other people
may have different experience what do
you think of the Finnish language is it
possible to be fluent in Finnish why not
the Finns are fluent in Finnish if you
live in Finland if you study the
language it's obviously different from
other European languages and therefore
it'll be a little more difficult for
that reason and that's about it so I'm
sorry that I didn't do this with Mark I
we tried to keep sending your questions
in and keep working hard on your
90 day challenge thank you for listening
bye for now